Everybody, "When We Walk with the Lord."
♪ When we walk with the Lord ♪
♪ In the light of his word ♪
It's Sunday in Lagos, Nigeria.
And it's time for church.
♪ What a glory he sheds on our way ♪
I've come to this delightfully neon house
of worship with a certain
degree of reluctance,
but when one of Africa's tech titans
invites you to his church, you say yes.
I have to warn you, I come
from a long line of atheists.
I'm not-
It's okay.
I'm not good at church.
That is exactly who we need at church.
Just experience it and
then that's it, you know.
No miracles.
♪ Your love is so wonderful ♪
♪ It's so high, I can't get over it ♪
♪ It's so low, I can't get under it ♪
Like everything here,
the service is high energy,
enough energy to make a nonbeliever smile.
♪ Nobody, nobody ♪
♪ Nobody shall like Jesus ♪
♪ Nobody, I say ♪
What I tell you or even show you next
will not do Lagos justice.
This is a city you have to feel
if you're to have any
hope understanding it.
More than 26 million people,
every single one of them,
striving and selling constantly.
For a laid-back Californian,
the energy here is exhilarating
and sometimes unnerving.
I've never seen anything quite like it.
I am here at the largest market in Lagos.
As you can see, it's
barely controlled chaos.
It's just block after block after block
selling everything you
can possibly imagine.
It's like this just every day?
Yep.
What, everybody just comes
here to get all kinds of stuff.
Anything, literally almost
anything at best prices.
Michael here is a local entrepreneur
and solver of problems
and my much needed guide to the market.
We're on this street,
which is pretty busy,
but I mean, there's streets in there
where there's like, no cars.
Busy.
Just wall-to-wall people.
Cars can't even get through,
so the whole market, you
literally have to squeeze
your way through, so it's pretty intense.
You can hear, they keep chanting
"oyinbo, oyinbo, oyinbo."
That's white man, white man, white man.
That's what they're saying?
Yeah.
That kissing sound, is
that considered rude
or that's just like
standard operated procedure?
It's standard operated procedure
to get someone's attention.
Seems like a hard way
to make a living, man.
It is, yes, but some people
make good money here as well.
Yeah?
You get it from the lowest prices
and you sell it for however
it smart you can sell it for.
Locals will be quick
to tell you that Lagos
is the beating heart of Nigeria
and that Nigeria is the
beating heart of Africa.
And they'll also tell you that if,
if Lagos could fix some
things, its infrastructure,
it's corruption, it's
old ways of thinking,
well, then there's a
historic economic revolution
at the ready, led by a nascent tech scene
that is ready to boom.
And no one wants to see this
happen more than this man,
who most people call E.
My full name is Iyinoluwa
Aboyeji but most people
can't pronounce it so everybody
calls me E, just the letter.
I'm the founding partner of
the Fund for Africa's Future.
Africa has seven tech startups
valued at more than $1 billion
and E started two of them,
Andela and Flutterwave.
He's often hailed as the
Zuck or Musk of Nigeria,
although, in this case,
that's meant as a compliment.
Starting a startup here was not easy.
I heard something about you guys
getting kicked out of offices.
Oh man, that's the stories for days.
What was going on?
Most people assumed if you had a computer
you were a Yahoo boy.
Yeah.
Is Yahoo boy, is that a
that's a Nigerian name?
That's a Nigerian term.
Okay.
That's why is this the
scams people always-
Scams, yeah.
So people who do scams,
we call them Yahoo boys.
Okay.
Yeah.
No disrespect to Yahoo.
I should probably take that
off and say something else.
We're actually in the part of Lagos
where you grew up, I think, right?
I lived here.
But what is this part called?
It's called Yaba.
How close is this to where
you actually grew up?
It's not far.
I could walk, my house where I was born
is maybe a 45 minute walk from here
and I went to primary school
literally right over those rail tracks.
Okay.
Could we have a little
drive around just see?
Yeah, we'll drive around, we'll see.
The haunts from your childhood.
See everything, yeah.
The population of Lagos has exploded
over the past 20 years.
The result is unplanned, unzoned,
put anything anywhere you can, havoc.
That said, much of the business and wealth
is clustered on Victoria Island,
which people describe as
the Manhattan of Lagos.
Even though he is well off now,
he very purposely rejected
living on the island
to stick to his youthful
and tech roots in Yaba.
Would you say this is the ground zero
of tech to startups, the talents?
The talent, yeah, it's cheapest,
best place to live.
So kind of where all the startups,
the dot-coms hanging out.
Yeah.
The startups are here in large part
because of the local university.
So we are on the campus
of University of Lagos,
which is one of the most
amazing universities.
And that's why Yaba is in such proximity
because the talent found
is easier to waft over.
Yeah, so there's a nice interplay between
that part of town and the university.
Yeah, exactly.
A lot of youth here.
Yeah, getting ready to go do big things.
But to do big things in
Lagos, you have to master
how Lagos works.
And learn how to navigate
its unique flavor
of business customs.
When I was at Adela, people
didn't know how we did it,
but we had 300 kids.
They were walking there with 300 MacBooks
each worth $1,000 dollars back
and forth every day in this neighborhood.
People were like, "How did you do that?"
But it was in the neighborhood watch.
Neighborhood watch in this case refers
to the Lagosian phenomenon of Area Boys.
These are people who control neighborhoods
in an unofficial but very real capacity.
One word to describe the
Area Boys might be mafia.
This sounds bad and
there's some truth to it.
Many people here though
don't really trust the police
to begin with.
And the Area Boys are a more local force
for maintaining order.
The trick is to learn how to
operate within the system.
I give their leader a title
as was my chief security officer,
I give him a badge, gave him a package,
including health insurance
for all these guys
and we're good.
We made sure everybody was safe.
The whole neighborhood was safe.
But if you don't know Nigeria,
it can be very hard to do business.
E's business savvy showed
itself early in life.
As a kid, he helped
his mom hawk stock fish
and ice blocks in the streets
and he discovered that
he was pretty good at it.
I just picked up entrepreneurship
skills very, very easily.
I imagine it came from
ultimately being the kind
of kid who really liked money.
Like money.
I loved money.
I love money.
I remember when I was growing up,
I wanted to be a policeman
'cause I saw they were the only ones
who were taking money from the drivers.
I didn't understand then that
they weren't supposed to.
And my dad made a very,
very significant decision.
His children would all go
to the best possible school,
even if he couldn't ordinarily afford it.
He went to Canada to
continue his education.
In the tech hotspot of Waterloo, Ontario,
he and a few friends
discovered their calling.
You had a little Nigerian
crew in Canada at Waterloo.
Yeah, pulled my people with me.
I started to tell my
Nigerian people, look,
there's a lot more to this
school than just getting
the degree and staying here
trying to get a passport.
At the time our motivations
weren't so noble.
I mean wanted to just
make money for ourselves.
He convinced his friends
to abandon their secure
career paths in North America,
come back to Nigeria and
try to make it big in tech.
In 2014, they started Andela, which aimed
to train up a new generation
of Nigerian coders
and get them remote gigs
from around the world.
It was the right idea at the right time
and it became a smashing success.
That allowed E to start his
payments company, Flutterwave,
another smashing success.
If somebody would've
told you you would create
two billion companies, would you?
Never believe.
Well, you know, one thing I'll say.
I did have faith that we
would do something big.
I just didn't know it was
going to be this big this soon.
Nigeria's tech scene
has been on a good run,
but its long-term prospects
face the same challenges
as other industries in the country.
The power infrastructure
is a terrible mess.
There are blackouts almost daily
and people rely on diesel
generators to get by.
It's roads and accompanying
traffic and just as bad.
The political system
is in constant turmoil.
Few people I talk to trusted
any political regime.
In general, conditions are unstable
and it's hard to get things done.
Everyone I talk to here is
optimistic about the future,
but people always point
back to the infrastructure
not really changing much or
or upgrading for decades.
The reality is our
infrastructure has been this way
for ages because we have
lacked for a long time
the investment to make it any better.
When I talk to American
capital, I think this,
the images of the starving
kid with a fly on their nose
is so stuck in their heads
that actually it's a lot easier
to have a conversation with
them about philanthropy
than it is about investment.
He knows of what he speaks.
He has gone to the heart of VC land
and was rather curiously
dismissed in spite
of his multi-billion dollar track record.
I sort of arrived Silicon Valley thinking
that what I'd done in Africa
would matter, but it didn't.
That's kind of twisted
because if somebody had done
the same thing in the US,
people would be falling all over them.
It is a different
standard, to some extent.
But I think it's better
because we've now learned
to be very self-assured
and confident in what we do here.
Uninterested in waiting
for foreign capital
to find Nigeria and Africa,
E has taken matters into his own hands.
His Future Africa Fund has invested
in about 50 startups here.
One is a company called
Releaf, which is trying
to modernize the business
of Nigerian farming.
It was co-founded in 2017
by this fella, Ikenna Nzewi.
He's Nigerian by background,
but was raised in the US.
Everything here comes
with a negotiation like,
like every step.
Small price, yeah.
How did you get used to this
or how did you figure this all out?
I wasn't used to it at first.
Or have you yet?
I started meditating.
It actually did me a lot of good.
You guys have, you've
got this mix of machines
and then software and technology.
Maybe should we start with the Kraken?
Yeah, let's start with Cracken.
The Cracken is basically
a really well-made nutcracker.
Sadly, no tentacles are involved.
The idea is to automate some
of the production of palm oil,
a process that's often done by hand here.
So when you're cracking open the nuts,
you want to apply enough force
that you crack the shell,
but not that you crack the
kernel that's within the shell.
It's kind of like this perfect medium
that you have to find between the two.
And like true tech try hards,
they used satellites and
AI to locate new customers.
This really funky map,
that is basically our ability
to see farms from space
and then go and meet the farmers.
So to do this, some AI was
just trained up to be able
to spot the pattern of
the shape of the palm.
Exactly, those triangles shaped trees.
Everywhere the orange touches
is where an oil palm farm is.
What called you back to the country
and called you to do
farming in particular?
I think it was a mix of like my passion
for seeing economic development in Africa
and also just the period of
time that we are living in.
Africa's really in the
period where it can boom
and so this is actually the point in time
to create solutions that will
expand into a large piece
of market share over the next 10 years.
Other startups in E's portfolio
are more like your typical
Silicon Valley joint.
Think app-based delivery
services for urban professionals,
though with a particularly Lagosian twist.
Eden Life is one example.
The company was started by
Nadayar Enegesi, a BFF of E.
He's one of the original crew
of Nigerians who met in Canada
and became the tech kings of Lagos.
You became like the, maybe I'm wrong,
it seems like the Nigerian equivalent
of the PayPal mafia or
something like that, right?
You started so many
companies are you guys-
Are we like celebrities?
No, no, we're not, we're not, we're not.
After helping build Andela with E,
Nad set out on his own with Eden Life.
The company delivers food
and does a smattering of
other chores like laundry
and gardening for busy
middle-class Nigerians.
It's these services of day-to-day
life to free up more time
for you to do whatever
you want to be doing.
Is that the basic idea?
Yes, exactly, exactly.
Everybody is like tremendous talent.
Everybody is working
harder and harder every day
to try to make it,
but there's different
roadblocks in the way.
For example, if you're
living in a place like Lagos
and you're going to work every day,
you're probably spending like
five to six hours in traffic.
He's not kidding about the traffic at all.
To get to Victoria Island
and its sweet, sweet opportunities,
people have to cross
this bridge every day.
It's two hours one way, if you're lucky.
Eden Life aims to help people
claw back some of that time,
and ultimately to become the go-to app
for all manner of services.
We describe what we are building
as the operating system for life
where you can find all of
these things in one place.
Nad certainly has Silicon Valley speak
down cold, though personally,
I'm not sure I want
an operating system for life.
Still, Eden Life represents the next stage
in Nigeria's tech evolution.
The country has a
seemingly infinite number
of mobile payment companies,
and of course, crypto everything.
What it needs now are new
ideas and lots of them.
So like Andela, Flutterwave,
I mean, had huge international investors,
are those sort of one-offs
or now those investors
have seen the success here
and that's brought in more
of is it still really hard
to get international capital for startups?
It's definitely easier
than it was in 2014.
Yeah, I'll say that by
orders of magnitude, right?
For multiple reasons.
One is the amount of talents that's here.
And so we're seeing a lot
more startups get funded.
The flywheel is definitely spinning.
The Andela mafia is a lot
like the PayPal mafia,
but with less ketamine and
fomenting of civil unrest.
Nonetheless, it seemed
like fun to reminisce
with the Nigerian coding kingpins
over spicy goat pepper stew.
The two close friends
met at school in Canada,
then came back to Lagos in 2013
to chase their startup dreams.
So how old were you when you met then
like 16 or something?
16.
Okay, yeah, so what'd you think?
Yeah, so my first impression of E was
why is this guy so grown up right now?
He was always helping
people with their essays.
Yeah, I really love essays.
To be fair, the Russian
kids were paying me, so.
When you told your parents
you were all coming back
to do this thing after
everybody's gotten to Canada,
everyone was okay or they
tried to talk you out of it?
Mine was an all-out war
'cause you know, keep in mind,
I was already here, right?
They're just like, "You
should've tried harder
to find a job.
What you mean you can't find a job?"
For me, it was just, I was ready.
I was ready, I was like,
yeah, this is the adventure
of a lifetime.
Everybody had to sleep on the floor
'cause we couldn't afford a bed.
So it was real hustle.
Proper startup life, man.
It was really bad.
Back then I used to drink a lot.
We used to do something
called Breakfast of Champions,
a vodka shot and some Red Bull.
I've had this breakfast
of champions a few times.
Was it scary or was it, like
you said it was just exciting
and you just had to see it through?
Well, to be fair,
this man right here is
a very sacrificial man
and he put in a lot to
make the transition smooth.
I try to keep all the
scary parts away from it.
It's fun.
The shorthand for what these men
are talking about is passion.
Did you go to this facility?
Yeah.
It's what drove them to
build their companies
and it's what's driving them now to try
and set Nigeria on a new course.
And the good news is that
if Nigeria has anything
in ample quantity, it's passion.
Good evening, ladies and gentlemen.
Welcome to Bogobiri open mic night.
Any kind of talent, please let me know
and we will get your name on the list.
It's Thursday night in Lagos.
I'm at the Bogobiri house. All week
people have been telling me to come here,
see some spoken words, some
music, all kinds of stuff,
so I'm going to go in.
Please make some noise for
Senior Boy in the building.
As with any open mic night,
there's a range of quality.
But the best acts are
face-meltingly great.
That greatness has made Nigerian
music a global phenomenon,
offering proof of the massive stage
on which Nigeria can play.
Thank you so much.
But to really talk about Nigeria
as a cultural force,
we have to talk about
one extraordinary man.
The charismatic, controversial
and legendary musician Fela Kuti,
who kicked off the Afrobeat
movement in the 1960s.
Fela merged Nigerian sound
with jazz, soul, and the blues.
He sang about love and life
and also about the plight of his people.
Fela went right at the government
and what he saw as its
corruption and neglect.
He was an artist and a revolutionary
all rolled up into one.
People still come to
pay tribute at this club
that acts as a kind of shrine to Fela.
Here you can bask in the
aura of the great man
and peruse various memorabilia.
I would comment on this exhibit,
but this is a family show.
All right man, Clinton is my
name, I'm on the microphone.
Let him know we don't play
right there, let's go.
What Kuti started with Afrobeat,
has since morphed into Afrobeats,
a glorious profusion of
West African pop styles.
These are the sounds of the
country heard on every street
corner in every club and in every home.
And this music has washed
over the entire world,
turning Nigerian artists like Burna Boy
and Wizkid into global icons.
Everybody sing.
One of the heavy hitters of the scene
is Banky Wellington,
a singer and rapper turned
entertainment mogul.
♪ Yeah, you are far from the regular ♪
So it started as me as an artist
to me starting a record label
and discovering other artists
and producers and DJs and
music business executives
all kind of got their start with us.
And then over the years
we've morphed into movies.
I'm a filmmaker.
I've co-executive produced some films
that have done pretty well.
You have.
You and your wife seem like
the celebrity couple of Nigeria
for what I could gather, right?
I'll let you see that.
Banky believes in Nigeria,
which is why he came back to live here
after going to university in New York.
He's even run for political office,
hoping to create more
opportunities for young people.
But not everyone who leaves Nigeria
is quite so eager to return.
I remember when I told my folks
that I wanted to move back
to Nigeria 'cause my parents
don't live here anymore.
I mean, they haven't lived
here for a few decades.
I remember my folks said,
"You want to sing, sing in New York City.
There people are singing there
like what are you going back
to Nigeria to do?"
A lot of noise has been made about
the japa syndrome.
What is that?
Oh, japa is when people leave,
they go for other opportunities
outside of the country
and we've seen quite a few
of our bright minds do that.
Nigeria suffers from a deep brain drain,
holding back the country's tech scene
from reaching its full potential.
Increasingly, though, Nigerians
who have made it overseas are returning
with their skills and their money,
sometimes permanently,
sometimes in more of a hybrid fashion.
One of these people is Kunle,
a deal maker with
Capricorn Investment Group.
Kunle grew up in Nigeria
and has made Africa his
focus as an investor.
So did you guys grow up pretty
middle class, upper class?
You know, I think from the
perspective that I look at it,
I would say middle class,
but I think my parents made
a lot of sacrifices for us
and I only know this looking back.
I studied chemical engineering
and had the opportunity to
go to the US to do that.
Did you ever think you'd be coming back
to Africa to build startups?
No, but I have about 30+ plus companies
that I've invested in
now, not just in Nigeria,
but across the continent.
Kunle brought me three
hours north of Lagos
to Ibadan, the capital of Oye State.
This is cool, man.
It's kind of so different than Lagos.
Seems like one notch down frenetic.
Yeah, definitely one notch down.
We had two missions,
to meet one of Kunle's
friends, a local politician,
and to visit Kunle grandmother.
First though, we'd have to get gas.
That's not a scene we'd
usually put in the show.
Then again,
it usually doesn't look like this.
To understand what's going on here,
takes a bit of explaining.
Shortly after I arrived in Nigeria,
a new president, Bola
Ahmed Tinubu, took office.
His first major act was to end
the government subsidies for gasoline.
This triggered an immediate
panic throughout the country.
People rushed to gas stations
to try and beat price hikes.
The gas stations were then barricaded
in a bid to control the situation
and simply filling up
your car became an ordeal.
The underlying problem here is
that Nigeria has lots of oil
but no refineries to process it.
Oil is exported, refined,
and then brought back,
with Nigeria, usually getting
the dregs of the production.
Africa's richest person.
Aliko Dangote just paid
close to $20 billion
to build the first new modern
refinery in the country.
You're building
one of the largest
refineries in the world?
Yes, it is 650,000 barrel a day.
So there's hope
that with the right
investments, things can improve.
But such examples are few and far between.
These economic woes make it even harder
for tech to flourish here.
And almost no one seems to believe
that the government
can make things better,
except apparently, for
this man, Adebayo Akande.
I don't know if you're aware of this,
but some people are cynical
about the government
here, you know, and how much progress?
What do you mean we're
not aware about that?
Like what are you talking about?
Actually I was one of
those people four years ago
and I think we can be on the outside
and complain forever
or we can actually try to
come in and make a change.
Bayo is a former entrepreneur
who decided to go into politics.
His mission has been to
modernize the government
of Oyo State and lay the
groundwork for tech companies
to set up shop here.
We're very interested
in internet penetration.
So we've laid fiber cables, fiber docks,
almost 1,000 over the past few years.
We'll probably do a couple thousand more.
Yeah, they always say the
second high speed internet
lights up in a country,
it's education improves,
job prospects improve, all of that.
Bayo is also putting technology
to work fighting graft,
which many Nigerians say runs rampant
throughout the government here.
We were talking too about
the, if $12 billion goes
to the construction of a new road,
only two billion actually
make it to the road
after sort of money's changed hands.
So what we've done here, for example,
one of the first things
we did was every single
contract procurement should be put online.
The whole process is transparent
and the monies to be
dispersed also online.
So full information, transparency
across the entire process.
All this, Bayo hopes, can
make life a little better
and easier for everyday Nigerians
and help convince young tech entrepreneurs
that they should build their futures here.
If you can just make life
a little better for them,
nobody wants to leave home.
If they can, they would
stay here and thrive here,
maybe earn from there, but live here,
so it's policies, man.
I mean, I trust Bayo,
he seems nice and well-intentioned.
But for the real talk on the real Nigeria,
I knew where we had to go next.
Welcome to Ibadan, this
is my grandma's home.
Thank you.
Lots of fun memories here,
so let's go say hi to Grandma.
Hello, Grandma.
Aw, good to see you, Grandma.
This is Ashlee.
Hello.
Ashlee.
Welcome.
Thank you.
Mrs. Grace Omotayo Apampa
was born in Nigeria,
went to college in England,
and came back in 1959,
just a year before Independence.
Is that you?
No, that's not.
No.
She worked at the University of Nigeria's
Teaching Hospital while
raising several kids,
and she remains a mom at heart.
The gentleman, let them eat it now.
You only give them one, one.
Grandma, they're busy, that's why.
They're busy with the cameras.
Tell them to help themselves then.
Yes, please help yourselves.
We will.
My grandchildren are all over,
they're scattered all over.
Are all over the world?
I'm happy that they're all over the world,
but I miss them.
Yeah.
Madam Grace has witnessed generations
of change here, but
still keeps a sharp eye
on current events.
I just learned about the
refinery on this visit.
I mean, the country should
be refining its own oil.
Yes.
We send the crude oil,
we sell it to foreigners.
They return it to us at a exorbitant rate.
Yeah, it's crazy.
It's crazy.
Yeah, how do you feel
about the young, the youth,
the youngsters and do they give you hope
for where the country is heading?
I think the future is bright for them,
but we have to come together.
We have to come home,
do this thing together.
Together, yeah.
Not running away.
We have to be together, stick and do it.
She's talking to you.
Yeah, she is talking to me.
I accept the challenge.
Back in Lagos,
you can find a number of
startups that Kunle has backed
with an eye toward making real change
for everyday Nigerians.
Tech investors have claimed
such noble intentions
since at least the stone age.
Hello, my friends,
welcome to Ibibio Class.
But here in Nigeria,
there's a case to be made
that tech might actually
make things better.
V, W, X, Y and zet.
Take Teesas.
They make an education app
and low-cost tablet for kids,
and also run in-person
learning centers like this one
with the goal of making
quality education available
for even the poorest households.
It was started by Osayi,
a Nigerian and former Exxon executive.
Today's May 27th and at
apparently is Children's Day
and is this like a Africa-wide holiday
or this is a Nigerian?
So it's mainly Nigerian.
We create a special day for the children
where we just celebrate
them, give them a good time.
Now we're going to stretch ourselves.
The way Osayi sees it,
the education in Nigerian public
schools is barely adequate.
Teesas aims to fill in the gaps
and get kids ready for college
and life all for just
a few dollars a month.
We're focused on the whole child,
not just academics.
Yes, we prepare them for exams,
but we also want 'em to
start developing core values
that would help them
throughout their entire lives,
like being proactive, right?
Social emotional learning,
can you say that?
Social emotional learning.
Being here they have access to the best
and the brightest tutors
and learning coaches across the country.
Happy Children's Day!
Another Kunle-backed company
trying to make things better
in Nigeria is Farmz2U.
It's run by Aisha Raheem,
who spent a few years
working in finance in London
before returning to her homeland.
I do go back and forth
because I also naturalized in England
so they're both my homes
and the two cities I've lived
long-term, Lagos, London.
Yeah.
Two mad houses,
but lots of entrepreneurial
spirit, so I love those cities.
Like Teesas,
Farmz2U is not super flashy,
but it is incredibly useful.
The company makes software for farmers,
helping them figure out what
types of crops buyers want,
when the best time is to sell a harvest,
and even how to get loans.
You've probably got people who have,
they're family's been farming
for many, many, many years
and then you're kind of
coming in with some new ideas
and then also you have to get
the technology in their hands.
In terms of even convincing them
and getting them to think about things
in a more technology-oriented way,
it's actually something
they're more open to
because of the impact of climate change.
The rains are coming later,
they're coming heavier.
So for instance, last year
in Nigeria we experienced
one of the heaviest floods
that we've seen in the last decade
and this is why they're more receptive
and really trying to understand
how can I do things better
because they're playing very thin origins.
Needless to say, Nigerian
farming logistics
is not the easiest business to be in.
But for Aisha, the challenges
are kind of the point.
You see a pothole on the
road, that's an opportunity.
There isn't constant light,
that is an opportunity.
There is corruption as the, you know,
traditional sense, that's opportunity.
What is actually corruption
is just that systems are not in place
to capture certain activities
because what might be
called corruption in Nigeria
might be called lobbying in the US.
What might be called a bribe in Nigeria
might be called a service fee in the UK.
What is in Nigeria is a systems problem.
It's not a people problem,
it's systems and processes
that needs to be in place.
By now I was feeling so inspired
by the possibilities of Nigerian tech,
I felt like I wanted to
get involved personally.
So I got myself an
entry-level job at a startup
delivering food to
customers all over Lagos.
Little did I know how intense
this job would get later on.
Over here we have the spaghetti.
We have spaghetti here.
And oil.
My new employer is a
company called Grocedy,
which aims to sell staple foods
at the lowest possible cost.
They work directly with
suppliers like Aisha's company
Farmz2U to buy food in bulk
and pass on the savings
to low-income Lagosians.
I give the order.
So this is the app.
My tenure at Grocedy
started out well enough.
We're doing the gold order.
It's a good basket.
All right.
You pack the food at a warehouse.
All right, I'll follow you.
You pop it in a delivery vehicle.
Teamwork makes the dream work.
Yeah.
Then you drive through the crazy streets
of Lagos to reach your hungry customer.
Lagos is a kind of a very busy place.
Sometimes it is stressful,
traffic, so many things.
You listen to podcasts, what do you?
Finally you arrive at the customer
where, because you have
a film crew with you,
all hell breaks loose.
We'd already had a few encounters
with the so-called Area Boys,
Lagos' neighborhood enforcers.
But these guys were
particularly aggressive
with their threats of violence.
All right, our arrival
wasn't that appreciated.
Little money was exchanged I think
and now we're going to
go deliver the groceries.
Well, I'm sorry we made your day-
No problem.
More hectic.
All right, man, it was nice meeting you.
Enjoy the groceries.
Cheers.
Sadly, that was the end of my career
as a Nigerian delivery man.
To ease the pain of my failure,
Kunle and his friend Michael took me
for a relaxing boat ride.
Destination, Ilashe Beach,
a resort area just outside the city
where chill vibes can be found at last.
People from Lagos come
out here just to relax?
Yeah, to relax.
To escape the chaos of the actual city.
Tell me how you guys met.
Goes as far back as the
primary school days, I reckon,
before he moved to the States
and I've been here just
keeping things going, I guess.
But you know, everybody, he
is got all the connections
'cause he's stayed.
If there's anyone that's plugged in.
Michael has made the most
of his decision to stay.
He now runs a business as
a kind of high-end fixer
and guide to all things Lagos.
Shout outs to the Afrobeats artists.
They're making Africa,
Nigeria, Lagos so popular.
Everyone is trying to come back here.
How much do you get when you come back?
People try to recruit you to come home?
I think it's a mutual
understanding that, you know,
maybe we playfully use it,
but people understand the whys
I think whether you stay
here or you live abroad,
our goal is just to make Lagos, Nigeria,
a better home for all of us.
Community, food, health, education.
I think if those basic
infrastructures existed,
you see less people wanting to move.
They'll still struggle,
but they'll know that like
the basic needs are met
and they would much
rather want to stay here
than go and live somewhere else.
Because it's home at the end of the day.
Yeah, it is.
Kunle and Michael continued
telling me about their many
prospective business ventures
and their hopes and
dreams for their country.
Good to see you, man, thank you.
Yeah, all right, yeah,
Seeing Nigeria through their eyes,
it's easy to imagine a bright future.
The truth, at least for me,
is that there's something
intoxicating about this country.
Its problems are so obvious.
Most of the country's
people are struggling.
There's dysfunction everywhere.
So many of Nigeria's
best and brightest people
have fled for brighter
prospects elsewhere.
But in the end, there's that energy.
The people who've stayed
feel it and thrive on it.
Anyone visiting will feel it too.
It's a kind of vibrating hum
that should be and could be
the backdrop for great things.